[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'idée que je propose c'est que des
maires se regroupent pour dire nous nous
sommes prêts à examiner cette situation
et s'il manque des signatures nouvelles
commandes d'avions rafale de la part de
l'indonésie c'est officiel 42 appareils
de combat sont commandés en deux temps
c'est un énorme contrat évidemment pour
dassault estimé à plus de 8 milliards
d'euros nous sommes prêts à nous
répartir entre nous le les signatures
nécessaires banque de parrainage oui
c'est une banque de parrainage
démocratique apolline de malherbe a
choisi une interview musclée gérald
darmanin lui a répondu de manière
musclée est ce que dans les termes qui
ont été employés il y a eu du sexisme je
n'en ai pas vu je soupçonne quand même
le gouvernement d'avoir inventé cette
machine qui ne sert à rien parce qu'on
savait que au micron étaient sains et et
1 1 un virus de de fin d'épidémie si
j'ose dire pour pouvoir faire ce cadeau
électoral mais vous allez dire que j'ai
mauvais esprits plus sains ficelle est
grosse et oui et puis ça veut passer de
telle sorte qu'on imagine que les grands
médias vont dire la macro le libérateur
ces propos rapportés dans le figaro
c'était ce matin valérie part dans tous
les sens en 2007 on parlait de sarko
matin midi et soir on parlait lui donc
mais là qui parle de valérie pécresse
elle est inexistante les propos assez
touche pour vous en faire et si c'est
pas si facile je peux vous même vous
dire et c'est entre guillemets oui mais
anonyme non nicolas sarkozy si nicholas
ray rice c'est maria mourani le figaro
nicolas sarkozy
ll radio privée valérie n'a rien compris
à la campagne et puis elles seraient
bien inspirés de me citer un peu si elle
veut que je la soutiennent
auriez-vous fonds pour continuer
pourquoi ne pas re tels que de chirac à
ceux de chirac elle a très bien mais
qu'il a fait une dix pendant cinq ans il
eut offert des six recours en or partout
en france partout en france du nord au
sud de l'est à l'ouest à part y compris
il en a gagné aucune donc les leçons de
campagne freymuth ses gardes et donc
voilà donc moi les losers ça ne
m'intéresse pas qui est important c'est
qu'ils se parlent avec valérie pécresse
et qu'ils aient confiance l'un en
l'autre et ils se parlent jeu je suis
sûr qu'ils se parlent vous n'imaginez
pas elle nicolas sarkozy soutenir
emmanuel macron sincèrement j'ai
toujours vu nicolas sarkozy prend ses
responsabilités soutenir sa famille
politique et avec succès faut quand même
rappeler qui a été condamnée pour
emplois fictifs donc voilà donc je n'ai
pas de leçon à recevoir de monsieur
stefanini d'eau qui reste à sa place
quand il viendra une compagne il viendra
me donner des leçons aux pieds des
turbines arabes elles qui font tourner
les centrales le chef de l'état est venu
annoncer à belfort la renaissance dit il
des nucléaire français
je souhaite que six paires 2 soit
construit et que nous lancions les
études sur la construction de 8,2 pr2
additionnel peu de temps perdu ce
président de la république a vendu la
branche énergie d'alstom à general
electric en 2014 il a mis fin à la
recherche sont nucléaire avec le projet
astrid il ferme fessenheim est là à deux
mois des élections il dit qu'il va
investir dans le nucléaire ouf il était
temps campagne un président de la
république sans débat démocratique
essaye de condamner notre pays à
l'obsolescence industrielle et
énergétique autour du nucléaire quoi
qu'il en coûte pour les risques emmanuel
macron va passer les 60 jours de
campagne électorale
à réparer 10 ans d re arrêter les
sottises inouïe qui ont été faites par
emmanuel macron qui avait annoncé la
fermeture des réacteurs nucléaires ce
qui fait que on ne les a pas entretenues
et qu'aujourd'hui on est obligé d'en
fermer parce qu'ils n'ont pas été
entretenues maintenant nous sommes
devenus le supplétif des intérêts
géopolitiques américain contre la russie
contre la chine c'est d'une
extraordinaire gravité